CAM TALBOT WAS EXCELLENT AGAINST
THE STARS ON HIS HOME  BY LINDE.
HE WILL HORSESHOE EARLY.
COUNT DOWN ON THE SECOND, HIM I
CATEGORY.
IT'S A TERRIBLE GIVE EIGHT GAME.
GETS PAST
GOES AROUND THE BOARDS, AND THIS
IS JUST RIFLED AT HIM AFTER THE
STARS CAN'T GETT, THAT'S THE LO
LINEUP CHANGE.
HE WAS SCRATCHED ONAS TRYING RE
LINE, CHIP IT IN, OETTINGER
STARTED TO DRIFT, BY
TO SURRENDER A SHORTHANDED GOAL.
HITS UP  THE
SAVE.. NET.
CENTERING FEED, UP HIGH, I, DEN
GETS BLOCKED BY
ORCHESTRATED TURNOVER, THE PUCK.
HAD OUT.
AND THEN SHIFT AND A HALF LATER.
LOOS THE LINE.
KAPRIZOV,
ROWS
-- CADAVEROUS.
KAPRIZOV IS LOST HAVIN F THE
RIGHT WING DUCK, TRIED TO FEED
THE AS THE GUY THAT WENT IN
THERE BABA KAPRIZOV.
DRILL BACK FOR